[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
ANNA KENDRICK: Hi.
I'll bet you guys
were really surprised.
I came all the way
through the audience
and then hung out over
there in the dark, like you
didn't know I was coming.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLY DECKER: Everyone
was like, hi, Anna.
[INAUDIBLE] But we're here
to talk about Anna's book,
"Scrappy Little Nobody."
If you haven't read it--
ANNA KENDRICK:
(WHISPERS) It's Anna.
MOLLY DECKER: --it
is hilariously funny.
It made my miserable New
Jersey commute enjoyable.
ANNA KENDRICK: Oh.
Oh, that's great.
MOLLY DECKER: Yes, it did.
ANNA KENDRICK: Thank you.
MOLLY DECKER: Well, it took
one day-- one day to read it,
so one day of commuting.
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah, it
took me a day to write it.
It's no big deal.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a year of my life.
MOLLY DECKER: But
to get started, if--
ANNA KENDRICK: Sorry, I
insisted that we use hand mics.
So I'm a jerk, but it's
just because I need a prop.
MOLLY DECKER: But in the book,
you talk about the paparazzi.
But other than that
and just talking to you
backstage, you seem
completely unfazed by fame.
And obviously,
you're really famous.
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah, it's just
where I'm really comfortable.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLY DECKER: So my questions
are A, is that true?
And B, what's the creepiest
thing a fan has ever done?
ANNA KENDRICK: I don't want
to put anybody on blast.
They might be in the audience.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I don't know.
People have shown
up at my house,
and I'm always like, bro,
you can't be my house.
It's like a nine-year-old girl.
And I'm like, dude, come on.
Come on.
But that's always
like, I don't know
what I'm supposed to do about
that, other than be like,
I'm in my bathrobe cleaning.
So I guess this picture
was worth it for you.
But I did once have a-- this
wasn't really even about me.
But I was shooting one of
the later "Twilight" movies
in Vancouver.
And I was in an American Eagle,
and I was looking at underwear,
as a lady is wont to do.
And a girl came up to
me, and she was like, hi,
are you going to see
Taylor Lautner soon?
And I was like, yeah,
because we were filming.
And she was like, I
have something for him.
And I was like, I really
need to say no to this girl,
because I was really
worried it was going
to be a thumb or something.
Why does she have it with her?
I was just in a store,
and she ran into me.
And why did she have a thing?
She carried a thing
at all moments
for Taylor Lautner in
case she ran into him
or somebody that knows him.
And I thought,
this can't be good.
This is going to be a
lock of hair or anthrax.
I don't know.
I can't be a part of this.
MOLLY DECKER: What was it?
ANNA KENDRICK: I don't
know, because I was like,
ma'am I really can't.
I called her ma'am.
She very young.
But I was trying to
keep my distance.
MOLLY DECKER: That is hilarious.
ANNA KENDRICK: Because I didn't
want to see a severed hand.
MOLLY DECKER: I'm sure
you've seen it all.
So you're an actress.
You're a singer.
So everyone knows she sings.
And I recently saw your lip
sync battle with John Krasinski.
And it's like,
oh, she can dance.
I was like, great.
She can do everything.
Now she's an author.
ANNA KENDRICK: That was
just me like sticking out
my butt pretending to dance.
It was supposed to be funny.
MOLLY DECKER: It was.
It was awesome.
But I was like, oh,
and now she can write.
She wrote a book.
She's an author too.
ANNA KENDRICK: I am amazing.
Is that your question?
MOLLY DECKER: You really are.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLY DECKER: Well, she is.
How long did it
take, and what was
the impetus for you writing?
What made you want
to write a book?
ANNA KENDRICK: Well,
I wrote a piece
for "Vogue," that looking back
on it, I had to turn it in.
It was supposed to be a diary
of an Oscars weekend one
of the times I was presenting.
And I had to turn it in Monday
morning after the Oscars.
And you're out pretty
late that night.
So I wrote it really quickly
and on very little sleep,
so looking back on
it, I'm like mmm eh.
But that's when I started
getting approached
about writing a book.
And I think I
thought at some point
somebody was going to stop me.
I was like, yeah I'll do that.
And I was expecting
somebody to be like--
I was expecting to turn
in a couple of chapters
and mutually go, this
probably wasn't a good idea.
Let's not do this.
And that didn't happen.
So I wrote--
I think I wrote the bulk
of it in this 45 day
where I knew that
I was never going
to become that person that
could write on my lunch break
and find time and find balance--
not really my thing, balance.
So I was between movies, and
I had this 45-day period.
So I wrote 2,000 words a
day every day for 45 days.
And it didn't have
to be good, but I had
to write something 2,000 words.
And I had to be really
strict with myself,
because if I give myself
an inch, I'll take a mile.
I'm a really bad person.
So that was where I
wrote a lot of it.
And a lot of that stuff wasn't
good and isn't in the book.
But that was kind
of where I started.
And then the year after that
was about expanding on things
that were interesting
and losing things
that weren't interesting.
And in a lot of cases,
that meant entire sections.
The section about
being nice didn't
come until right
toward the very end,
because I was in a bad
mood and was like, oh,
here's this stupid
thing I wrote.
You're probably not
going to use it.
And my editor
liked it a lot, so.
MOLLY DECKER: Liked it?
Oh, that's wonderful.
ANNA KENDRICK: [GASPS]
Whose phone just went off?
[LAUGHTER]
Shame.
MOLLY DECKER: For those of
you who haven't seen "Camp,"--
so you talk about "Camp" in your
book your, first movie 2003.
It's amazing.
And I love the show
must go on scene.
I must of watched on
YouTube a million times.
Loved it.
ANNA KENDRICK: Oh, thanks.
MOLLY DECKER: I love it.
I just watched it this
morning with somebody,
because I was like,
I love it that much.
But you talk a lot about how
that experience shaped you.
You worked with a lot of younger
actors and actresses on set,
like a camp, like a
real kind of camp.
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah.
MOLLY DECKER: And
so the question
is, what about that
experience do you still
hold on to in that character
specifically, Fritzi,
what do you still
hold on to from that?
ANNA KENDRICK: Well,
the character was so--
was such an interesting
experience for me, because
at the time, I was 16 or 17.
And I just like wanted to have
my makeup done and be like--
and be able to be like,
guys, like I'm in a movie.
And I'm playing someone normal.
And that wasn't the
case, because Fritzi
is the smelly girl.
And now, I would love to
play a character like that.
It was just about getting--
realizing that vanity just has
no place in performance or art
or--
it's just going to
hold you back, so.
MOLLY DECKER: You
know the scene where--
is it the director-- was like,
you're a creepy little girl.
I was like, this is a
hilarious character.
ANNA KENDRICK: I know.
I know.
MOLLY DECKER: I loved it.
ANNA KENDRICK: I know.
But there were definitely
times when the director had
to convince me, because
I was like, everybody
is going to hate me.
Everybody's gonna
hate this character.
It was definitely a lesson.
But when you're 16, you don't
want to play the smelly girl.
MOLLY DECKER: Right.
But it is great.
You've got to watch it
for anyone who hasn't.
In the book, one of my
favorite quotes from the book
was when you said
your dad only cries
when describing the storyline
of the movie "Rudy."
ANNA KENDRICK: That
is a true fact.
MOLLY DECKER: I was just like--
I literally laughed out loud.
I thought that was hilarious.
ANNA KENDRICK: Then,
they come in, and they--
they put their shirt down.
And they say, this for Rudy.
This is for Rudy.
I was like, what the fuck
is happening right now?
[LAUGHTER]
We were in an Applebee's.
MOLLY DECKER: That's so funny.
ANNA KENDRICK: True fact.
MOLLY DECKER: But similarly,
the title of the book "Scrappy
Little Nobody," and you
talk about sticking up
to the bully in the school.
You love that whole underdog,
David versus Goliath
sort of thing, which is kind
of what "Rudy" is all about.
So it seems like
similar to your dad.
ANNA KENDRICK: Whoa.
MOLLY DECKER: Did you
not make that connection?
ANNA KENDRICK: No.
MOLLY DECKER: Oh.
ANNA KENDRICK: I'm not
a very smart person.
I don't know why they
let me write a book.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLY DECKER: So as I was
reading it, I was like, wow,
she loves the underdog.
Her dad loves the underdog.
What is it about being the
underdog, and what are you--
why do you miss being like
this scrappy little nobody?
ANNA KENDRICK: Well, I think
everybody feels that way.
No matter where you
come from in life,
you feel the insecurities
that you have.
You carry those with
you your whole life.
And the best thing
you can do with them
is turn them into
something productive.
So that's why I sing so loud.
And because I have no technique.
MOLLY DECKER: You once--
[LAUGHS] This cracks me up too.
There's so much in
this book that is
just-- you will laugh out loud.
You said once on
Twitter that your dream
is to live in the Thanksgiving
episode of a '90s sitcom.
ANNA KENDRICK: So true.
MOLLY DECKER: Which I
can totally relate to,
I totally get.
And I was equally as
excited in the book
when you started
describing all the holiday
parties that you will no--
you'll never throw.
But you have a vision of them.
ANNA KENDRICK: Yes, that
was really fun to write.
MOLLY DECKER: And I
just want to know,
what's up with that
whole holiday section?
ANNA KENDRICK: I don't know.
And I think there
was only one of those
that I had to come up with.
Because it wanted it to have
a nice kind of pacing to it.
The rest of them, I genuinely
have planned parties
in my head with great
detail and talked about them
with one of my best friends.
And the Christmas party
especially, every single detail
I had laid out in my head.
MOLLY DECKER: Every
room has to be
decorated with Christmas decor.
ANNA KENDRICK: I
think it's because I
don't have much
of a social life,
because I have turned
myself into a workaholic.
So I'd fantasize about having
parties and having friends
over.
MOLLY DECKER: But
you never throw them.
ANNA KENDRICK: So yeah, I
don't know what that's about,
other than like--
I don't know.
Does anybody else do that?
MOLLY DECKER: I can
relate, but I don't plan--
ANNA KENDRICK: Plans
their dream-- no?
MOLLY DECKER: I don't
plan them out that way.
But I can relate.
I love the holidays.
I love "Home Alone."
You talked about "Home
Alone," in the book.
That There's a holiday theme.
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah.
I think it's--
I don't love Christmas.
It makes me really stressed.
Any forced fun, like birthdays
and New Year's and stuff,
like have the best
time of your life right
now is-- it seems
counterintuitive to having
a good time.
But the season around
it, I really do love.
I know I'm supposed to
hate Christmas music.
Fuck you, you hate
Christmas music.
Christmas music's great.
So I love just
decorating everything
with tacky tinsiley garbage.
MOLLY DECKER: Who doesn't?
It's great.
So you describe a lot of hustle.
So as a young girl,
you would take the bus
from Maine, where you lived
with your brothers, sometimes
your dad, into New York City.
You were on theater,
performed a lot, worked
a lot as a young kid, really.
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah.
MOLLY DECKER: How old were you?
ANNA KENDRICK: I started
coming to New York
to audition when
I was 10, I think.
And I got--
I did the-- my first
Broadway show at 12.
And yeah, I don't know.
I didn't think a lot about it.
It just felt like it
was my only option.
It's just what I wanted to do.
I remember particularly
when I moved--
I think at 12, it
seemed more like--
people just assumed that
it was my parents being--
MOLLY DECKER:
Pushing you to do it.
ANNA KENDRICK: --creepy.
But particularly when I
moved to LA when I was 17,
there was a lot of like,
whoa, I could never do that.
And it was like, I had to.
I didn't have a choice.
It was the only thing
I could think to do.
It just was necessary.
MOLLY DECKER: What
advice would you
give-- there's
people old, young,
all types here in the audience.
But what advice would you
give younger, up-and-coming,
working on your career
in New York City?
What would you give the
younger 12-year-old you advice?
ANNA KENDRICK: The
shitty thing about this
is I only have a piece
of truly terrible advice.
I say this in the book.
And I do feel that
it's terrible advice.
But I was told very, very young,
like when I was 11 years old,
don't have a backup plan.
That's terrible advice.
But I think if I had
one, I would have caved.
I absolutely-- there was not--
even though I felt
like I have to do this,
this is completely necessary,
and this was my only choice,
I never felt like so that
means it's going to work out.
MOLLY DECKER: Right.
ANNA KENDRICK: So
there were definitely
times where I felt like I wish
I hadn't listened to that advice
and I did have my backup plan.
Because I wanted to opt out.
MOLLY DECKER: Yeah,
and you moved to LA--
still young.
You didn't go to
college, moved to LA.
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah,
did not go to college.
MOLLY DECKER: Bought
your Ikea furniture
and just worked and
went on auditions.
It's like actually--
ANNA KENDRICK:
Yeah, so my advice
is don't have a backup plan.
MOLLY DECKER: It's OK,
don't have a backup plan.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA KENDRICK: And
do drugs, I guess.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLY DECKER: Hilarious.
All right.
We'll take our first
audience question.
ANNA KENDRICK: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So first of all, thank you
so much for taking the time
to be here.
You're hilarious.
ANNA KENDRICK: It's my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: I want to
know a fun question.
What has been your
favorite set to work on,
your favorite movie set,
and your least favorite?
And why?
ANNA KENDRICK: Ugh.
That is a really hard question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA KENDRICK: I like that.
I did like "Up In The
Air" a lot, because it
felt like we were making
a really small movie,
especially because I mostly
interact with George.
And I interact with Vera Farmiga
a little bit in that movie.
It felt like it was just the
three of us making that movie.
And it was kind of a big
production and a big budget.
But at the same time, doing
something like "Into the Woods"
was so dream come true.
I remember standing with Tracey
Ullman, who's like a goddess,
and being on that set in
Pinewood Studios in London,
where a lot of the-- some
of the scenes in the woods
we did outside in the woods.
But some of it was on a stage,
and the stage was so enormous
that you couldn't-- we
couldn't tell where it ended.
And Chris Pine was
riding in on a horse,
and Tracey and I were
just like, can you
fucking believe that we're here?
And I was like, I
can't fucking believe
I'm having this conversation
with Tracey Ullman.
And it's how you think
every film set will be,
that it'll be this
production where
you get to wear this corset
and this period costumes.
And that's really
the only experience
that I've had like that.
And to make it interesting,
I'll say that was also
my least favorite set.
Because it was
cold all the time,
because they built a
real forest in a studio.
And it was so huge that
we couldn't keep it warm,
and there were dirt everywhere.
And they had to pump so
much smoke into the studio
to get the atmosphere right
that I would-- this is gross,
but I'll just share.
I would go home and blow
my nose, and it'd be black.
AUDIENCE: Ew.
ANNA KENDRICK: Eww.
Ugh.
So it was one of
those things where
I was so happy to be there.
And then, my ribs and feet
hurt at the end of the night,
because the costumes
were very unforgiving.
So it was one of
those sets where
I had to be like so grateful
to be here and remind yourself,
this is a dream job.
So happy.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANNA KENDRICK: Thank you.
MOLLY DECKER: That's awesome.
In the book, you
talk about wanting
to be a doctor when
you were little.
That's the story
that your mom loves.
ANNA KENDRICK: That's when
I thought I was smart.
MOLLY DECKER: You were
going to be a doctor,
but you're an actor/singer.
You didn't have a backup plan.
But if you weren't doing this,
because you clearly love it,
what do you think
you'd be doing?
ANNA KENDRICK: I'm
hoping I'd have
one of those bullshit
racket jobs, where
I was a life coach or a
personal organizer or something,
one of those made up.
I mean, I'm sure there are
people who do it well and are
effective, but I'd just
be really bad at it
but convince people.
I'd have a nice aesthetic
on my Instagram,
so people would
be like, she seems
like she's onto something.
MOLLY DECKER: Are you
good at advice in general,
outside of the career advice?
ANNA KENDRICK: No.
Very bad.
MOLLY DECKER: So that's just
what you would like to do?
ANNA KENDRICK: Mm-hmm.
MOLLY DECKER: That's hilarious.
ANNA KENDRICK: Just ruin
people's lives willfully.
MOLLY DECKER: Oh my God.
OK, question over here.
ANNA KENDRICK: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
coming, by the way.
ANNA KENDRICK: Thanks.
Thank you for speaking
into the microphone,
even though it's clearly not on.
[LAUGHTER]
I like that about you.
You're a rule follower.
I like it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ANNA KENDRICK: OK.
AUDIENCE: Often,
I think at Google,
we get asked what our
five-year plan is,
and you're very successful.
ANNA KENDRICK: I know.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Where
do you [INAUDIBLE]
in the next five years?
What are your goals?
ANNA KENDRICK: Do you know?
I don't fucking know.
Do you guys know?
Do you have answers when
people ask you that?
Can I have a show of hands?
Do you have a teed up answer?
Nobody?
You're Google.
What the fuck is going on?
[LAUGHTER]
No, I think that's one of
those insane questions.
I feel like a sociopath
would have a great answer
for that question.
But I don't have a plan.
Honestly, sometimes
I feel like my plan
is to work as hard
as I can until I
have a nervous breakdown
and have to say
that I have lupus or something.
I don't know.
I'm excited all the time
and terrified all the time.
How do you feel?
AUDIENCE: I feel-- that's great.
ANNA KENDRICK: How do
you feel about my life?
AUDIENCE: I feel like you've
got it all figured out.
ANNA KENDRICK: OK, great.
I need a lot of validation.
I appreciate that.
MOLLY DECKER: OK,
we'll go over here.
ANNA KENDRICK: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So I was in acapella group in
college and recently went--
I'm not going to sing
with you, don't worry.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA KENDRICK: No, I wasn't
gonna do that either.
AUDIENCE: Recently went
to ICCA Championships
in New York, which were
definitely not as fun
as the movie, "Pitch Perfect."
And I'm just
wondering if you can
talk about how just making
that movie in general,
how fun it was, the musical
rehearsal that went into it?
ANNA KENDRICK:
Well first of all,
I can tell you the reason that
real acapella competitions,
while very impressive, are
not as fun as the movie,
"Pitch Perfect,"
because they actually
have to sing live and dance.
So the dance moves
are more like walking.
And we are trying to
get down to the best
of our non-dancer abilities.
So we fall on the floor
after the dance numbers.
So obviously, we can't
actually sing during them.
If you could do an ICCA--
this is a real competition.
If the ICCAs could
prerecord their vocals
and then dance to them, they'd
really be on to something.
But then, they'd just be
like pop stars in the '90s.
Ooh.
Burn on pop stars in the '90s.
Is that-- I don't know.
Did that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Not really.
But I--
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA KENDRICK: OK.
Sorry.
What else did you need to know?
AUDIENCE: Just
curious if you could
talk about just
how much fun it was
to make the movie in general?
ANNA KENDRICK: It
was really fun.
AUDIENCE: OK, good talk.
MOLLY DECKER: All right.
All right.
We're going over here.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Hi, Anna.
I was just wondering, since
you mentioned earlier that you
wanted to play more roles like
that 16-year-old smelly girl--
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah.
Oh my god, you think
I could pass for 16?
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm 19.
ANNA KENDRICK: I
don't understand
what's happening, but great.
AUDIENCE: It just
kind of made me
think about what kind of advice
you would give to someone who
isn't really comfortable in the
position they're in, like how
you would find an
environment where
you are safe to be yourself.
ANNA KENDRICK: My
friend, Ben Platt--
AUDIENCE: Whoo.
ANNA KENDRICK: Oh, that was the
biggest name drop of the night.
I think he said it best
in his Tony speech.
He said, what
makes you different
is what makes you powerful.
And I was like that
thing, yes, what he said.
So yeah, it's--
I think finding your tribe is
important, whatever that means.
And I always hate that--
I hate that thing
of like when adults
are like, oh, none of this
will matter in the real world.
Because if you're in it,
it sucks for you now.
If somebody asked me to suffer
through four years of feeling
targeted and ostracized,
I would be like,
I really don't want to do that.
And you telling me that it
will be over in four years
doesn't make it better.
So I think just trying
to like find strength
in yourself if you
feel misunderstood
and knowing that
you are powerful,
and the things that make
you odd and the things
that people don't understand
are the things that give you
value in the world, I think.
I'm just paraphrasing
what he said.
He said it better.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLY DECKER: That's great.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
ANNA KENDRICK: Thanks.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
You seem like a pretty
grounded person.
So I'm wondering,
what do you focus on
outside that industry
that makes you grounded
or makes you happy?
ANNA KENDRICK: I don't know.
I should probably have a more
profound answer for this,
but I grew up in like a black
Irish humor kind of family.
And finding humor was
always the thing that--
how we got through everything.
And I'm a big fan
of gallows humor
and just undercutting
everything.
So I idolize comedians.
I just did a movie
with Chris Morris.
I don't know if you guys know
the British comedian, Chris
Morris.
He's just the darkest
motherfucker around.
So that kind of thing
just reminds me.
It's basically like I can't
hang out with my older brother
all the time anymore, because
we live across the country.
But he would be the guy
to be like, you're being
a pretentious piece of shit.
Like, chill.
And since I can't
have that, it's
like I just try to
look at Morgan Murphy's
Twitter accounts
and stuff like that.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
Thanks.
MOLLY DECKER: I have a
related question, sort of
like outside the industry.
If you were on "Jeopardy" and
could preselect the category,
what would it be?
ANNA KENDRICK: Oh, my.
What do I know a lot about?
The script of "Clueless"?
Yeah.
Oh, that's a good question.
And it really makes you realize
the things you know really well
are mostly embarrassing.
[LAUGHTER]
I guess like 30
screwball films, I guess.
I like those a lot.
MOLLY DECKER: You know
those-- the lines by heart,
know all the characters'
names and scenes?
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah.
MOLLY DECKER: That's awesome.
OK, we're going to take
you over here, Richard.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I became familiar
with you from
your early theatrical career.
I saw "High Society" when I was
trying out in San Francisco.
ANNA KENDRICK: What the--?
AUDIENCE: I know.
I went to Latin Club.
I was very popular.
But then I saw "Camp"
when it was in theaters.
And I was curious,
what motivated
you to go from theater to
film and if you would ever
consider a return?
ANNA KENDRICK: Well, when I
did "High Society" in New York
Randy Graff was in it, and she--
I became very close to her.
And I loved her very much.
And her cousin, Todd Graff,
directed the movie, "Camp."
So she told me that I should
audition for this movie.
And especially
because that movie
was about musical
theater kids, that
seemed like the
right thing to do.
And then, I had such
an amazing experience
with Todd and with those
kids and kind of realized
that while there are--
you're more likely
to run into assholes,
I guess, in terms
of movie actors.
But I think actors
are out of their minds
but wonderful
presences to be around.
And I had such a great
experience on that,
that I wanted to
keep doing that.
And I also started to
actually understand
the mechanics of making a
movie, and that was exciting.
Because the first
movie was mostly
me being totally terrified
and going like, wait,
I have to look over
here, even though she's
standing over there
and not understanding
what was happening.
Learning about the
filmmaking process
was really exciting to me.
I don't know if that
was interesting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] And are
you considering going back
to theater at some point?
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah
I would love to.
I look at Bette Midler
in "Hello, Dolly!",
and she can do that
because she's Bette Midler.
So I think I would want to
do a new piece so that it
wasn't-- just selfishly, to
take the pressure off myself.
Just I wouldn't
want to follow up
on anybody else's
performance to do a revival,
but I would love
to do a new piece.
MOLLY DECKER: When were
you the most nervous?
Because you did an opening
number for the Oscars, right?
That must been a
little nerve-wracking.
ANNA KENDRICK:
Yeah, I think the--
I can tell you that the times in
my life I've-- the three times
I've been most nervous was doing
[INAUDIBLE] stage at Carnegie
Hall.
I did this weird performance
when I was like 13 years old,
and Julie Andrews was there.
So that was terrifying.
And then the first time
I did David Letterman,
like fully thought I
was going to pass out.
And then the performing
at the Oscars.
MOLLY DECKER: The Oscars, yeah.
The Oscars is a big one.
All right, let's take
a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ANNA KENDRICK: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So before
you mentioned
that vanity will hold you back.
And I was wondering-- obviously
there was a point in your life
when you transitioned
between auditioning for roles
and not having a name and
having the celebrity status
and people knowing you.
What did that
transition look like,
and how did it impact you
as a person or your career?
I'm assuming you don't
audition anymore?
ANNA KENDRICK: I don't know
if this is exactly what you're
talking about.
But the point where
I suddenly started
going on red carpets and
stuff and promoting the movie
and getting dressed, and people
were doing my hair and makeup
stuff, I've never
felt more hideous.
Because people,
like teams of people
are putting hours of
effort into how you look.
And that's never
happened before.
And then, you go
on a red carpet,
and Joan Rivers
is like, C-minus.
And you're like, what the fuck?
This is the best I've
ever looked in my life.
[LAUGHTER]
So that is a rude awakening.
I had also never
been in a position
to be compared to
Natalie Portman.
That shouldn't happen
to any woman ever.
So I always thought
like, I do OK.
I get mine.
And then I was
like, no, no, no no.
I'm not supposed to be compared
to Blake Lively, which is
the movie I'm doing right now.
So that's good for
my self-esteem.
But yeah, it just took
me kind of saying like,
the best thing I can do with
what is happening in my brain
right now is know that I have
never had to lie awake at night
and go, do I offer anything?
Am I only getting the work that
I'm getting because I'm so hot?
And that I have
to just go, well,
that's a blessing, because
at least I know I have value.
[LAUGHTER]
So really, let's say a prayer
for the really, really pretty
girls.
They're the ones
who have it rough.
Am I right?
Those poor things.
AUDIENCE: Real quick follow-up.
Oh, never mind.
ANNA KENDRICK: I have no idea
if that was the question.
I honestly was thinking
about how weirdly soft
this microphone is.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
MOLLY DECKER: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hello really big fan.
So I guess I was wondering--
you've written this book.
You're working on
a lot of movies.
How do you manage your time?
How do you manage
doing all these things
that you want to do that
you do for your career?
ANNA KENDRICK: That is
such a great question,
and I will tell you
when I figure it out.
Honestly, I've tried to
do a couple of things
recently to correct the fact
that I felt like I was--
I'm going to get really real--
I was letting everybody
in my life down.
Because I just didn't--
I had spread myself too thin
and said yes to too many things.
And therefore, I
was constantly--
I felt like everybody
was mad at me.
I wasn't maintaining friendships
and family relationships
and have recently tried to make
sure that that is happening.
So I guess just having
to say to people,
no, I absolutely can't do that.
I think I forget
that when somebody
wants you to do something,
you can't really
gauge how important
it is, because it's
just what they want.
So actually saying, this
is how much I really
don't want to do
this, so let's talk
about how important these things
are and make some decisions.
And that's a really
uncomfortable place to be.
Because normally, I feel
more like I'm going,
is there any way that we could?
And the second that I get
that, ooh, we kind of planned,
and this has been worked on.
And it's been decided.
I was like, oh, then, totally.
Then, totally.
And having to
assert that no, I'm
going to have to like
compartmentalize here and make
some time for my momma.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANNA KENDRICK: She
gets really mad at me.
MOLLY DECKER: Back to
the book for one second.
Just in writing it, what's
your hope or one thing
you want people to take away?
Is it more laughter
or story of you?
ANNA KENDRICK: That was
what I wanted people
to take away from it.
I was like, I just want
it to be really funny.
That was my goal.
And since I'm not
a writer by trade
or a comedian or something,
that was like the best thing
that I could hope is
that people would laugh.
And my editor was
like, maybe put
some serious stuff in there.
And I was like, ugh, ew.
But actually, I think the thing
that I get comments on the most
is the section about being nice
and how it's just not something
that I'm prioritizing anymore.
So fuck all of you.
And that was something
that I thought
for sure I would send it to my
editor, and she would be like,
you're coming off a little
bitter in this section.
But she was like,
no, this is right on.
MOLLY DECKER: It's authentic.
And to the question
you just had--
it's you.
It's you.
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah.
MOLLY DECKER: That's great.
Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Howdy.
ANNA KENDRICK: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that going into "Camp,"
it felt pretty
natural since it was
more musical theater oriented.
And I was curious
how it felt to go
into the role in
"Rocket Science," where
it was heavily debate-based.
And it's a weird
culture to begin with.
So I was just wondering
your opinion on that.
ANNA KENDRICK: Well
it was really fun.
And the writer and director
came from policy debate,
and he did have an
intense stutter.
And he didn't join because of
a manipulative psychotic girl,
so I was made up.
But I had a great time with
that because I knew that he was
getting all the details right.
They had this really specific
thing about what boxes we--
yeah, look at your face--
we used.
And knowing that like
certain subcultures
can be explored in each--
in different movies was
exciting and knowing that you
would get that recognition of--
and when I watch movies about
theater or making movies,
I love it when they
get everything right.
And it's really frustrating
when they don't.
So I think it's always fun to
be able to honor that and know
that somebody is going to
go, those fucking boxes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, thanks.
ANNA KENDRICK: Thanks.
MOLLY DECKER:
Question [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for coming.
And I love you.
Don't worry, I won't show
up at your house, though.
But my question is, why did
you want to include Google
as part of your book tour?
We need affirmations too.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA KENDRICK: You
guys seem smart.
I don't know.
Like I always think it's crazy
that you guys would want--
professional people
would want to talk to me.
And I always feel like I
get something out of it too.
And you guys have asked
really great questions,
and you're all young
and attractive, so just
looking to get laid, really.
How's that for-- is
that a good affirmation?
AUDIENCE: That was perfect.
ANNA KENDRICK: Very attractive
group here at Google.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MOLLY DECKER: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi I know
we talked a little--
or mentioned your
Twitter account.
And I just wanted to
ask you about that.
I actually don't have Twitter.
I don't really do Twitter.
But when I see funny tweets
being posted elsewhere,
they're often yours, and
they're often very funny.
ANNA KENDRICK: [GASP]
AUDIENCE: So I was
just wondering,
how does that-- that's
always a question.
How do you-- do just wake
up and think of funny things
and then post them?
Or how do you go about
creating your Twitter?
ANNA KENDRICK: It's just when
I think of something funny.
I follow Andy
Richter from Conan.
And when I go on Conan, he was
like, you should tweet more.
You're funny.
You should tweet more.
And I was like, I
am not holding back.
It's not a quality
control thing.
It's a supply and demand
brilliant thing on my part.
It's just like when
I think of things.
And sometimes as an exercise,
I'll try to think of a joke,
and it'll always go down OK.
I'll sit in an airport
and try to come up
with a joke and tweet
something, and it's always
like that was all right.
So it's more just like weird
things will pop into my head.
And recently, I texted
some of the girls
from "Pitch Perfect,"
because I was like,
I need a female opinion
on whether I can post
about that thing where
you put in a new tampon
and then you're like, did
I take out my old tampon?
Like five minutes later.
MOLLY DECKER: I saw that.
I saw that meme.
ANNA KENDRICK: And
they said, yes.
So I was like, OK.
So I'm not the only one.
I've never done it,
but I always think it.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLY DECKER: OK, over here.
AUDIENCE: Hey, thanks
for being with us.
I thought you were great
in the "Trolls" movie,
and I wanted to know if
you could give something
to Justin Timberlake for me.
ANNA KENDRICK: Is it a thumb?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: No, but seriously.
Voice acting versus live acting,
is there anything about it
that you like more or less?
ANNA KENDRICK: The
big joke is like you
get to go to work
in your pajamas,
and I would do that anyway.
So yeah, voice acting is
preferable in the sense
that you get to be comfortable.
But it's like the best acting
class I've ever been in,
because you get--
on the films that you get a
direction, and you're like, OK.
And I have that
kind of physical--
emotional response to, I
see what you're saying.
And I want to execute
on that right now.
And then like 10 minutes
later, you get to do it,
and you're filtering it through.
But I have to hit
this mark, and I have
to have the cup in this hand.
So I switch it there
and make sure I'm
in my light or whatever.
And it's being able
to just follow through
on those intentions
like the second
that you have them
is so fantastic.
And it's the most
freeing experience,
because you don't
have to like fight
through these layers of the
filmmaking process, which
is important.
And I honestly
can't stand it when
I'm working with somebody
who's like all over the map
and is like completely--
the camera can follow you.
But there's equipment
in the background.
So the shot's unusable.
So congratulations on the great
performance you just gave.
It's not going in the movie.
So I really want to
like respect the process
and make sure that I'm doing my
job to the best of my ability
while not making anybody
else's job harder.
But to not have any
of those obstacles
is so freeing and so amazing,
I would do it forever.
It's so much fun,
especially that character.
She's out of her mind.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ANNA KENDRICK: In the pink way.
MOLLY DECKER: Well,
today, the question
I wanted to make
sure to ask you.
You were in "Twilight
The Eclipse,"
or "Twilight Eclipse," which is
literally the only link today's
eclipse that I could find.
Actually, someone sent it to me.
But we were talking a little
earlier, and a lot of people
are saying that today's
eclipse is going
to cause life transformation.
So I wanted to know--
ANNA KENDRICK: Are people
really saying that?
MOLLY DECKER: They really are.
So what are your
thoughts on that?
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA KENDRICK: For real
true fact, people--
MOLLY DECKER: For true fact.
I read about it.
[LAUGHTER]
ANNA KENDRICK: Wait.
I have so many
follow-up questions.
What is going to be life
transforming about it?
Is this-- genuinely
they think it
will have an effect like on wow,
we're all under the same sun
and we're all one?
Or like in the way,
your horoscope will--
MOLLY DECKER: They
say whatever was
starting to shift in
March 2016 is going
to come to fruition today.
So I don't know.
You'd have to think
back to March 2016.
There's also some bad spirits.
ANNA KENDRICK: Oh, OK.
So it's nonsense.
MOLLY DECKER: That was
supposed to come out--
ANNA KENDRICK: OK.
No, no, no, no.
I just wanted to make
sure it's nonsense.
It's not like somebody had
some kind of a fact-based--
we're at Google.
Come on.
They don't have
time for nonsense.
MOLLY DECKER: All right.
Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So how do you go about
picking a project?
And somewhat related,
is there anything--
because you've had a nice kind
of run of different genres--
is there any project
or film you have not
done that you're really
excited about possibly
pursuing in the future?
ANNA KENDRICK: Well, I did--
like silly bucket
list, I had always
wanted to do a Christmas movie.
And I'm doing one later
in the year, so uh.
As far as picking projects, this
is one of those answers like
the five-year plan where I feel
like I should have an answer,
and I don't.
Honestly, you read a
lot of bad scripts.
There are a lot of bad
scripts in the world.
There are a lot of bad ideas.
And when there are good
ones, people fight over them.
And sometimes it lines up
that there is a great script,
and I fight harder.
And that's great.
So it always seems
pretty obvious to me
like what I'm going to choose.
And every now and then, there'll
be something that's good,
but I'm like, I've played this
character three times in a row.
And you don't want to then have
that thing of like, ooh, you're
kind of a one-trick pony.
And I'm sure that applies
to a lot of areas of life.
Maybe it doesn't,
and I'm just trying
to make you some seem
relevant for you guys.
But I think it's
not like there's
some kind of like a master
stroke to any of it.
And knowing that, nobody's
had a perfect career ever.
That's another question that
people ask you a lot is like,
whose career do you
want to emulate?
And nobody's perfect career.
Everybody's made crappy movies.
And knowing that's kind
of freeing, knowing
that you're going to
screw up and make mistakes
is kind of freeing.
Because it just means that
I should choose things
based on what I think is going
to be personally satisfying.
And then a number of them will
work, and a number of them
will be really terrible.
And that's OK.
MOLLY DECKER: But do you
ever feel a strong intuition
that this is going to
be a great movie or this
is going to be a great
experience going into it
before you take it?
ANNA KENDRICK: Yes.
And the last movie that I had
that with did not work at all.
Nobody liked it.
So you just don't know.
And nobody goes into
any movie, any project,
any work-related thing
trying to make it bad.
And sometimes, it happens.
And I don't know why.
But again, I think
that's weirdly
freeing, knowing you
can't control it,
and you can make all
the right decisions.
You just have to try to
experience joy however you can.
Often for me is watching
the "Sorry" music
video, because those
dancers are great.
MOLLY DECKER:
Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hey, there.
I loved hearing it earlier about
your affinity for '90s sitcoms
and wanting to be in one
of the holiday scenes.
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And as
Molly will attest,
I'm kind of a '90s
sitcom aficionado.
So I'm curious, what
is your favorite one,
or what character would you wish
you have played in one of them?
ANNA KENDRICK: My favorite
one is the one with Chandler
in a box, where he's
in the-- and he's--
you know what I'm talking about.
AUDIENCE: "Friends," yeah.
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah, where he--
Chandler kisses
Joey's girlfriend,
and Joey makes him spend
Thanksgiving in a box.
But they're all like
dressed really cute,
and they have banter.
And we're all pretending
it's not insane
that you put your
friend in a box.
So that's my dream.
And also, Thanksgiving
episodes of like--
these aren't '90s, but
"Community" and "Brooklyn
Nine-Nine," I love that we're
just suspending disbelief
that you spend your
Thanksgiving with your work
colleagues and your community
college and a group of friends,
and none of you are going
home to see your families.
We're all just fine with that.
AUDIENCE: The magic of
the movies, of course.
ANNA KENDRICK: Exactly.
Exactly.
I'm trying to get
friends like that.
You guys wanna have
Thanksgiving together?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was a big fan of
"The Last Five Years."
ANNA KENDRICK: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I was wondering
if you could talk a little bit
about making that movie
and your inspiration
for the role of Cathy.
ANNA KENDRICK: That was a close
runner-up for my favorite film
set.
I was going to maybe say
it earlier, but I thought,
there'll be like one person--
and two.
And I loved-- that
was so much fun.
We had no time and no
money, and we sang a lot--
we sang as much
live as we could.
Yeah, that was such a dream,
because my favorite musical
is "Parade," by
Jason Robert Brown.
And I had somehow--
like cosmically, I had never
heard "The Last Five Years"
So they sent me this script,
and I read the script
without knowing the music.
And they had the
lyrics, and they just
had like stage direction
and the lyrics.
And I was weeping reading it.
And then the next
morning, I woke up
and listened to the
soundtrack as I read along,
and I was just beside myself.
So I think it was meant
to happen that way.
Otherwise, A, I'm one
of those people where
I would have-- it would
have been impossible for me
to not sing it in
the exact intonation
as the original cast
album, like "Rent."
Is like-- nobody?
I am grateful that I didn't
have to overcome getting
that voice out of my head.
And I don't know.
I think I had some
personal experience
that I was drawing
on for that role
and just being able to
work with Jason Robert
Brown and his amazing wife,
who was our music director, who
likes to make the joke that the
only person in the world who
thinks that "The Last Five
Years" has a happy ending
is his new wife.
OK, wrong crowd.
That's fine.
I thought it was funny.
And yeah, I just couldn't
have had a better experience
than that.
And I think if we'd
had a little more time,
we could have gotten a
little more coverage.
Some of those
angles I'm like, why
are we holding this so long?
Oh, right, it's because we
didn't shoot anything else.
But sometimes, movies
are held together
with love and duct
tape, and that's
what makes them really special.
So I'm glad you liked it.
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANNA KENDRICK: That means a lot.
MOLLY DECKER: I think we
have time for one more.
AUDIENCE: I'm actually
going to apologize,
because if I had known I was the
last person asking a question,
I would have come up with
something more serious.
ANNA KENDRICK: This is exciting.
AUDIENCE: So a number
of years ago on Twitter,
you had a back and forth
between yourself and Dwayne
"The Rock" Johnson about
making a movie called
"Rock And Pebble."
ANNA KENDRICK: Yeah, "The
Rock and the Pebble."
I'm the pebble.
Get it?
[LAUGHTER]
Because I'm small.
AUDIENCE: So now, if you
were to make this movie,
what would the movie--
what would be the movie's theme
and what would it be about?
ANNA KENDRICK: You
guys are smart people,
so we could come up with this.
We could storyboard this right
now and pitch it to The Rock.
I don't know.
I feel like he really excels
in like a buddy cop comedy
kind of thing.
So I think just a kind
of classic buddy comedy,
like on a mission.
And I'm kind of useless
the entire time,
and he has to save the day.
But then like
right at the end, I
do something
[INTENTIONALLY MUMBLES]..
Something like, oh, no,
this tiny crawl space.
And I'm like, this is my moment.
So I think, yeah, it'd
be the first buddy cop
comedy to end with a high-stakes
crawl space sequence.
AUDIENCE: So when's
it coming out?
I'd like to get tickets now.
ANNA KENDRICK: Whenever
"Game of Thrones"
is finished, so
like 2020, I guess.
Because we're not trying
to compete with that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANNA KENDRICK: Thank you.
MOLLY DECKER: It's amazing.
All right, guys.
Let's thank Anna for
coming to Google today.
ANNA KENDRICK: Anna.
[CHEERING]